and you'll need all three for my next
recipe
[Music]
my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondies
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
and gently melt that butter
sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a bit lighter
slightly fluffy
off with a gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make
it well in the middle
sort of whisk you see
it's already gone nice and blunt
love it
give that
a really good mix
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
and nice and smooth lovely
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk in two whole eggs
just give them a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yeah
it's so simple whisk in the eggs looking
for that nice sort of Rich texture
smooth paste
you can see why we call these blondies
beautiful next teaspoon of baking powder
baking powder in then half a teaspoon of
baking soda
aerates the mixture and gives it that
little tartness you'll see this sort of
Rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half a flour in
and then the other half in you'll feel
it sort of almost nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages this stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon next
I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies dried
cranberries they bake beautifully but it
gives the Blondie a really nice sort of
chewy sweetness in the center next and
white chocolate
[Music]
I'm not gonna grate it let's chop it up
just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
now chocolate in lovely fold that in I
want a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt it'll be like little pools
of white melted chocolate in the center
now baking tray
a small little knob of butter
and a grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
Chris proof allows me to maximize on the
white chocolate inside the mix no grease
with paper the chocolate can melt and
almost stick to the tray so the paper is
just a really nice insurance policy
secondly won't that rise and that sort
of crispness now with the mix get your
spatula all the way around I don't see
anything left in that bowl position the
ball over your tray
nice and carefully
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of a spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp
on that soft gooiness in the center
make your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
that smells incredible
look at that crisp Edge on the outside
in that sort of soft gooey Center leave
that to cool down and it's going to sort
of firm up and wrinkle but it'll stay
nice and gooey in the center once it's
cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
mouth-watering blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
in great bacon as with all cooking
sometimes less is more
look and taste spectacular when they're
done well
and it doesn't come any simpler or more
stylish than my next dish wonderful
baked cheesecake for me food always has
to be impressive but when it comes to
desserts often you see Sponge sugar or
wild decorations remember simple is
always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
now cream cheese leave it out of the
fridge for five or ten minutes go nice
and soft trust me your arms will be
thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is the New York
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar
spending the amount of time I do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake Rich delicious but
so simple work the bowl
lift the ball to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
nice and creamy now
get your eggs
add the eggs to the mixture bit by bit
doing it this way it's more efficient a
you're incorporating a lot of Air B the
mixture doesn't separate
the last of your egg
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
cheesecake a day keep the Bingo Wings
away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk stop something going
Lumpy
now I want to scent that cheesecake
I've got the freshness zest of the lemon
in there I want to sort of tart it up
even more fold in some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through be careful to
crush them
then Grease the cake tin with butter
this will ensure your cheesecake slides
out beautifully
get your mix
fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
mixture hits the bottom of the cake tin
The Raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom and also stops all these
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture and the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
foreign
slightly soufflaid up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color I wanted on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest yet the most
stylish cheesecakes anywhere
beautiful
[Music]
slow cooking isn't exclusive to just
Savory dishes it's a clever way to
transform fruit into wonderful desserts
giving them an amazing sticky Jammy
intensity
invest a bit of patience and my next
recipe pays off big time
Indulgence and bursting with flavor
caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful Rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in a rows
take some Rosemary and just peel that
down look at that really nice fragrant
stem get your scissors trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp Point bring your three figs
together
and just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently Rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of Blossom
with vinegar leave them to sit there for
five minutes they sort of marinate I
know it sounds odd to use vinegar in
your dessert but trust me it gives the
dish a fantastic sweet and sour taste
I'm gonna make a really nice caramel
four or five tablespoons of sugar now
flatten that out and get it nice and
even when the sugar is even caramel
Cooks evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in the one thing you
don't do is shake the pan rapidly
and sit almost like sort of a lake
defrosting and it's hitting to the
center it's bubbling it's still not dark
enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas not with butter in
there
gently whisk in
the butter is cooling the camel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe Olay
next add a lug of the balsamic vinegar
beautiful
for that nice dark richness
of a camel a little touch of water in
there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
a fix and sort of place them in gently
lovely
and then just added all that lovely
little marinade
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar and Balsam and vinegar
there's something so tasty
based those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
Fig sort of just absorbs the caramel
delicious
so easy
now into the oven 190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
they smell
is incredible onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that camera
now douse the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese the
freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs I'm gonna finish that now
it seems zest and then some little
nibbed almonds
and the rich creamy Jam texture of the
Fig
with a ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
taking figs to a completely new level
[Music]